[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody how's it going here
max is back two days in a row now yep
might be three but yes you guys we are
here live games while live yada yada
yada you're here for some Dragon Ball Z
Kakarot which is what we're gonna be
playing today checking out the first 90
minutes max has played a little bit of
it he's gonna be able to give us the
lowdown as we make our way through the
beginning of the game a little bit to
toriel's a little bit of intro but we'll
get to some good story so if you have
any questions in the chat while we're
going through this make sure you send
them our way well answer as much as we
can but you know this game's not
officially out until Friday so it's
gonna be a little bit of a sneak peek
and yeah so send over those questions
hope you guys are having a great day
happy Wednesday we're halfway through
the week and let's go fresh new games
right here for you guys so I don't know
if you all are Dragon Ball fans out
there but this is total fanservice
like pretty much the best parts well the
most important parts of the anime not
like any of the filler episodes are just
remade in this game so if you guys watch
the anime this is basically a love
letter to you guys or if you haven't
seen it I guess this would also be yeah
this is actually for me like I wasn't
that heavy into it but I'll let the
cutscene play out
dad
[Music]
[Music]
piccolo you came I like to do a little
image training every now and then to
make sure I don't get too rusty time to
see what I can do and you're just the
guy to help me do that
oh and we're in sorry guys you know
classic arena fighter huh anything stand
out or a difference from previous lines
you know I didn't play like xenoverse
anything like that I think the only one
that took super seriously was spiders
[Music]
yeah I don't know what to say about it
right this second so it's just the intro
there's nothing like major that I can
say but I think once you get in like
non-fighting parts kind of slows down
[Music]
son Goku in the chatons and I saw enough
already
glad I preordered can't wait okay no
time to give you the crown this tutorial
now
long intro
yes Randal who asks is this only a one
player game this is only one page yeah
there's no multiplayer in this right now
but yeah the games pretty fun there's a
there's a lot of open world there's
fighting a lot of story so there's a
good pace of pretty much it's not like
just constant fighting and constant
story and constant open worlds kind of
switches off between the types
I sound like a little intro to this yeah
or something it has a little homage
pretty much like okay okay like the
old-school anime has like these really
kind of I guess corny but lovable like
title screens and like music so it does
all of that like really well and yeah so
again if you watch old-school Dragonball
Z like this is you're gonna like this
game a lot for sure there's a lot of
loading though you know there's already
gonna be a day one patch to fix that I
read about it oh okay well there's been
a day one patch and this would take two
patch yeah there's been a couple patches
so far so that might have been a part of
it but make sense Vegeta
and that's why everyone calls you rad
it's the right things will be different
on the next planet mark my words if you
screw up again
I will kill you wait I just something
yeah I think my little brother Kakarot
was sent to a different planet I'll bet
he's still there you have a brother I
didn't think there are any Saiyans left
besides us if he joins us the rest of
the universe will be ours in no time the
fact that he's your brother doesn't
exactly fill me with confidence
what planet was he sitting to I think
it's called
but now that I think about it I haven't
heard anything about him taking control
of doing
[Music]
yeah that's that's old-school right
there
and it does feel like I am watching the
anime yeah
dad we better head home or mom's gonna
be really mad at us sorry for getting a
bit carried away Gohan I was fighting
somebody super strong super strong yeah
a guy going by the name of piccolo yeah
well he used to be called Demon King
Piccolo and he was real bad to the bone
he's the strongest guy I've ever fought
in my whole life I don't think anybody's
gotten me more pumped up than him I want
to fight him again so I'm hoping to get
stronger and soon I'd be afraid to fight
someone like that you know I didn't
you'd be just fine if you trained
yourself up a bit I don't think mom
would like that very much
ah that's right I totally forgot that
chichi asked us to get some ingredients
for her how could I not remember that I
think I think oh yeah right let's just
see if we can't find some apples around
this place okay Gohan sure is full of
energy right so this is like where the
RPG part of it yeah there we go so now
we're in the sort of open world part
right now if you guys wanted to switch
to Japanese with subtitles or if you
like even English up to you guys I will
go by the general consensus of the
checked yeah so yeah this is walking
around collecting more what do you say
leave it to me hey it looks like you
found it now looks pretty though it is
pretty pretty yeah
Gohan looks like he's having a blast
having a blast running around collecting
apples and a basic part of the game just
walking around and collecting stuff
there's a lot of collecting the open
world and you'll get to see later
there's like four bloat around me
collect 200 that's not very Canon
somehow yeah exactly they're seeing
someone it at least here the Japanese
for a bit at least okay yeah we'll try
them all out for like a few minutes I'm
curious about Portuguese - I don't know
fast Portuguese language and I don't
blame you hang in there I got an idea
we'll catch some fish and then head
straight home okay it's kind of slow
pace right here cuz like if you go out
of Gohan's ranges like run ahead leave
your child before you probably
responsibilities of being a parent
ya can't just run off have you
responsible this is nicer actually yeah
it's kind of just a relaxing part
there's definitely like you know super
exciting parts and super relaxing parts
and parts you can just sit and relax and
watch
the movie we didn't watch anime again
it's a good recap for it and I heard
they're actually gonna have like
expanded backstories that are supposed
to be tailored oh really yeah there's
the new character bond you also looked
like the pre-order bonuses okay I didn't
watch all they rich my enemies so I
wouldn't have exactly yeah apparently
there's like new Laura that's actually
supposed to be legit in this game so
adorable and wholesome like carrying
your son let's go fishing
yes this game officially comes out
Friday playing it a few days so we
wanted to share with you guys come to
think of it this is your first time
fishing isn't it yeah it is alright then
let me show you how I used to do it back
when I was your age
it'll be fun should be able to catch
something here alright let's get started
was that long pause horny and kind of
weird sometimes
yeah by dipping your tail in the water
you can feel the fish moving around
pretty neat huh I mean I haven't done it
in a while since I don't have a tail
anymore
but when I told my friend bola about it
she actually made me a makeshift tail to
fish with yeah I see nice oh ok so what
do you say let's catch us some fish
and attach the tail yeah it gets okay
yeah you have to use your fake tail to
try out some tail fishing you could make
someone's gonna make a tail fishing ride
IRL oh yeah if the fish is big enough
though you would have to have some
strong balance to stay on the pier and
not get pulled into it
oh it's Goku though I'm thinking about
myself if I was using it good tonight
got some fish and apples y'all yeah all
this fishing is really working up an
appetite you know what I mean let's eat
some of these fish I mean we got plenty
so it's corny boys I'm supposed to be
taking this back right now yeah carry
with one me too now
but yeah how many people in the chat are
like diehard Dragon Ball fans like what
do you feel what are you thinking so far
about what you're seeing
I could definitely see some hardcore
fans now already there caught the tail
before you know I had fun today - thanks
for your help I'll teach you how to fish
next time so we can do it together okay
snapchat is loving it so far which is
awesome can't go wrong with some Dragon
Ball Z Michael said looks kinda empty
and I saw some footage of like a city
map that looked really really busy and
like dense yeah might just be because
we're you know in a early stage so far
but yeah that's also something I've
heard it's a I think it's just a spacing
of everything I think you just feel
really empty and large but I think
that's a part of because the character
moves so fast right so yeah exactly once
you get to the open a world like because
you could fly around it changes hey I
found this sacred text of martial arts
over here in the grass while you're
fishing yeah that's the part that's not
something I love
let's keep on moving along actually I'm
gonna see if I can find the bug give me
a second it's gonna run back
um Andrew says I'm a hardcore fan but
I'm a little concerned since I spent a
hundred bucks on the deluxe edition I
hope I get my money's worth without it
feeling like a chore I think that
edition is probably a good choice
because it comes is that the one that
comes like the music pack and all that I
don't know what happened because I
thought that was like the best I've seen
the collector's edition though has this
really cool like figure that's like yeah
I kind of want to see the whole box now
I didn't get to see the toy inside he's
looking actually so it's nice yeah it's
like a diorama figure 8 inches the
figure is basically like this scene
right there like the dinosaur it's like
flying and then these super on the cloud
and they're floating above like a
scenery yeah ok that's scene right there
that's literally the diorama
that's pretty cool ah this is nice this
looks nice this is definitely giving me
some like you know Kingdom Hearts vibes
we have to fly to the other world
yeah it is kind of relaxing actually
just to kind of fly around those are the
pure heart take notes EJ's episode went
chichi try to get on the flying Nimbus
is just fell further
[Laughter]
yeah sorry about that we did some
training too you're supposed to
introduce go on to Master Roshi and the
others today about that
I promise I'll remember next time forget
it
what are you waiting for get in here I
need to get cooking right away that's
mom
socks are in convince her to make me
some food because she's mad this is so
adorable though like yeah wifey please
feed that look good - it does look good
mm-hmm is it almost lunchtime yet I was
gonna be lunchtime through the stream oh
yeah I like the sound effects they do
like in the middle of those like
conversations really all that was so sad
I'm going to see Master Roshi but you
can't come I think these are cool
because this is like little snapshots of
the og animation 19 Dragonball Z this is
like og Dragon Ball kind of filling in I
mean it's cool cuz like for me who like
didn't watch entirety Dragon Ball Z it's
good to like know like little bits of
information from the enemy
and then there's like Thomas H as homage
for all the fans out there for like just
remaking all the enemy scenes just
really cool [ __ ] whenever you're
hungry thanks GG your stuffs the best
really gets the blood pumping and the
muscles moving right go on
cool oh yeah all right Lee oh that's
right she's a separate board oh yeah so
these aren't those are important that
community board it's kind of hard to
fill out right now cuz I don't have any
friends right now that little ball on
top there it's a dragon ball I got it
from my grandpa after he died you that's
not all you got from him you were also
named after him
oh my go on look so handsome oh my she's
some kind of southern we're leaving for
real this time
Goku don't let anything happen to our
little Gohan and go hon be on your best
behavior
alright now like I mentioned earlier I
haven't like you know seeing all that so
is there anything like that but from
what I know the Dragon Balls are pretty
important he just has it on top of his
head that's not a that doesn't seem a
little dangerous you know I I'm almost
in my mind you know thinking of it like
an infinity stone a child yeah I mean I
guess I like on their own they're kind
of harmless but it's just like it's
really
these mysterious wish-granting orbs are
known as the dragonballs and it's around
these dragon balls that this
extraordinary story unfolds with new
challenges and adventures awaiting Goku
and his friends so every turn I gotta
say the animation
[Music]
CC was looking for the Dragon Balls when
she ran into me we ended up going on
adventures together we probably wouldn't
have met Master Roshi and the others
okay I'm actually might change this to a
Japanese just to switch it up yeah let's
see how it sounds
let's want to see what it's like read by
nature he says hey son I made this hat
for you and stuck this insanely precious
mystical gym on it I'm sure no super
villains I'm like you're killing for it
that was my thoughts exactly I was like
man that is terrifying but yeah I know I
haven't seen the shows I mean I've seen
like some movies like some of the ones
that came out in select theaters those
are like wait for it yeah exactly I know
there's a million different storylines
as it seems from an outside view that's
why I was kind of interested in this too
since it recaps everything into one -
yeah it's it's a good like
small capsule of all the his name is
Gohan Gohan oh so you named him after
your grandpa huh
yeah suits him don't you think well
she's not a pervasive man of culture I
feel like some you know the enemy is
that have five billion episodes it's
really daunting to be like yeah I'm
gonna like catch up on this yeah
actually for that reason if anybody has
that like fear yeah like watching too
much of the animes this is a good game
to be interactive with it and like
actually understand the basics of the
story because I heard they cut out like
a lot of the filler - oh yeah yeah this
is like the really important parts I
could have sworn you two are talking
about how you've both been slacking off
on your training yes yes there's no
fooling you is there Master Roshi
it would seem you've both forgotten that
training is a daily activity not
something you do only on special
occasions you should be moving learning
playing eating and resting every day
that's the way of the turtle school
school okay with you there now to make
sure you two never forget your daily
training that's now I've got a little
challenge for you
come report back to me once you've
finished your training yes sir master
roshi yes sir Master Roshi now time to
get back to my usual enjoyment I don't
like that yeah let's not find out what
that is so to change the language I have
to go back to the menu so I mean a title
screen so I might have to do it real
quick if I want to see make sure we
receive you come back to this part but
yeah I'm gonna skip that means I what's
up chat while we well we see if we can
spoiler all these other save data areas
that Max's been using I can get back
there real quick
but yeah what's something you guys are
looking forward to or maybe heard about
and aren't sure it's confirmed or
something I don't know we're answering
some questions for you guys here yeah
max has been playing he's holding it
down yes you got any questions about the
beginning the game I can try and answer
as much as I can
cuz we played or I played about three or
four hours into this now
a pretty good amount of time under my
belts all right so we're going to
Japanese
all right yeah
to the ball Wally says is are the sole
emblems is the salt emblem system like
social links in persona so like you you
you get more friends and you get their
emblems and then you can link them
together in certain ways to get certain
abilities and power-ups so but each
person you play as has different ones so
like we're obviously leveling up all
Goku's right now but later on when you
play as a different character you'll
have to basically start from scratch
community board or whatever
I think the community board is actually
a general one throughout the game oh
okay but there is different characters
that like represent different things so
like chichis is a cooking like yeah of
course that's him so funny I thought he
was covering out like that part of the
mandolin but when he was scrolled next
he could see it don't think of down easy
yeah so you'll get more characters that
you like adding together so if you get
like 10 over here and then like Yamcha
over here it can be like oh gee crew and
then they'll be like a power from those
three so you see the more of those later
I want to get more friends all right
we are what are we playing on thank you
okay yeah we are on ps4 wasn't sure if
you're on Xbox or not but yeah we're
currently playing on the PlayStation 4
phantom from Indiana says how long do
you think the game is I heard rumors of
about 40 hours for just story that
sounds about right
because I got past Vegeta Ark and that's
pretty far into the game and I wasn't
three or four hours okay and then
there's like five hours after that so
plus some other stuff that's probably
gonna be a lot harder than I was playing
yeah it's gonna be a while Kiani would
have made a good Goku Gianni he could
just play every role ever invented and I
would be happy
would you say this compares to something
like a I'm trying to think of other
arena fighters I know you play it like
any play jumpers great somewhat similar
there's a lot of always in the air in
this game
Arina fighters all right definitely like
not on my list of games Emily oh yeah I
wanna yeah go and get that and check it
out but having it mixed with the RPG
side of it and this game specifically
makes it a little over yeah yeah when
they were just talking to each other in
that previous cutscene there was no
voice lines right yeah it's kind of that
just because that specific interaction
didn't have my science the other small
interactions just won't have any talking
over it I'll just be like you there I
was like we didn't even get to hear this
yeah but whatever you guys know I was
talking about anyways thank you Josh who
says he thinks our channel is the best
you you're the best
oh there we go
[Music]
like the volume is louder in certain
areas and really low in other yeah like
actual shows sometimes on TV yeah I
think just a movie like the full movie
cuts things like this a lot louder is it
louder or softer you feel like I felt
like Oh softer in the cutscenes it takes
a while sometimes I think we'll get to
the open world pretty soon
and that's when we can like actually
start talking a little bit more about
like the spacing of the game the neutral
game of the game do you think jagan Ball
super is gonna be DLC well we already
know there is going to be DLC that's a
it's radish I know it's right it's guys
I just called
[Music]
[Music]
all right be real chat what's your power
level and don't give me no because I
know it's not you your personal power
yeah I'm gonna give myself a solid you
know six point five I think that's a
fair one right there six point nine I
feel like I was better than that farmer
but not by much so
oh snap all right so this is like we're
like the real game comes into play wait
yeah
yep okay so this is like magneto flight
mode but they get to like go into flight
mode to like I knew everyone was gonna
say nine thousand lire everybody else
negative ten all come on you're not a
negative thing I believe in you Ritchie
says mine somewhere between 60
[Music]
I believe that one I think the coolest
thing is just flying around actually
like it feels really good to fly around
there's like there's all this open space
and like when you're just walking around
like damn this is like obviously lazy
once you like take off I think that's
supposed to help with the feeling of
like you really do have some power yeah
you know like oh look how fast I can get
over there but then when you're on foot
you're like well this is actually really
really can't even tell him if you wanted
to
right so it's just a lot of flying
around in orbs and fighting enemies on
the open world it's not like breath of
the wild because that's just one
singular map but there's multiple open
world maps like this so this is like one
of five or six probably these are all
pretty big yeah until all of these orbs
do different things for you depending on
the color got some herbs though gotta
get them herbs but yeah flying fields
just very satisfied
so let's go just fly up to them do you
know if it's like other artis where like
you approach them like from behind
you'll like it like surprise you know I
feel like you'd be just right through
them it'll like kill immediately but it
takes a while to get to that point yeah
as each character have their own level
and XP poll asks Chris got to the point
where so like right now like the story
kind of makes you switch off between
characters as you go through the story
so you don't have like a party right so
you like place Gohan here you play hello
there go through there sometimes have
like partners but you can't choose like
oh I'm gonna go play as you yeah I want
to play as video or coca ready yeah I
see interesting yeah but I think later
you might get to the point where like
you can like solidly just play and
whatever you want yeah you know they
keep saying it's not an open-world game
it's not an open-world game but it's
pretty big it's like a bunch of non
open-world Bob Jones hello how are you
welcome back in the sia as always
is there a photo mode or something like
that photos in this would lick straight
from the animes that I have not seen I
don't think there's any camera that
would be cool though
yeah would make sense especially with
how pretty of the worlds are looking
yeah I think that would be nice to have
a function like that to have like a
camera mode like a selfie mode did a lot
of game sound right as well I really
prefer Japanese that's just our their
difficulty modes no there might be a new
game plus mode but I haven't seen
anything that I kind of wanted like
having a harder difficulty or like it's
not like easy easy but it's easy to get
like s-rank like he's like taking over
the kids
do we know what the sub stories are in
the pad we're talking about DLCs cuz I
know they did mention that there's gonna
be like two new episodes and a new saga
in the DLC or a story arc a new story
arc I'm not exactly sure if you're if
you're talking about DLC specifically
I'm not sure
is there a season pass yes there is
there will be a season pass like these
like I just mentioned a second ago they
already talked about a couple of new
episodes and they say
[Music]
and you don't really get all of your
abilities that ones either you unlock
them as Muzo through yeah there's like a
skill tree yeah it everything and of
course like it's beginning the game so
you don't have much but once you get
farther you can get like like modes you
can switch off into and then like if
you're talking about the day one patch
as far as I know the only things they
were changing in the day one patch were
loading times and like general quality
of life stuff yeah I've been directly
felt or seen it yet this game look worth
it so far I mean you're a Dragon Ball
fan yes yeah I would say if you're a
Dragon Ball fan yes cuz there's also
gonna be new Loren and new like expanded
backstories if you're new to Dragon Ball
I would still say yes because this is a
good chance to get caught up with the
rest of the with the story itself yeah
that's it yeah interested in Dragon Ball
and you want to know the story without
watching nine hundred episodes yeah this
is a good catch up and like a more
interactive catch-up right in terms of
fighting style for me personally arena
fires isn't my personal style but I do
like the RPG elements in here so far
yeah I don't know I would say for me
personally I would play this just so I
can learn more about the story unless
because I want to play the fighting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we could just keep switching back and
forth spoken languages yeah we could
probably change the text we won't be
able to understand anything
you can take my don't talk to me or my
son ever again
I saw someone earlier in the chat say
explain the fighting controls block
dodge there's actually a bursting
teleport
sort of similar like a vanish and
lighters and you can only use vanishes
when you have can't just like this all
the time open to attack your first boss
or was that just like another entry
level things I was like that was pretty
I like how you just like are getting
destroyed though oh my god I know get
out the ground
[Music]
oh boy
[Music]
would you guys join forces with piccolo
be honest in real life yeah they know
best green boy he's also best dad better
dad that go through all right yeah
s is on s is on esses and for the chats
sake let's switch it back to English
because you guys are you guys are
growing gray hairs right now you know
you should take a breather it's fine we
got you switch it back right now
I received the item
cronies that's great
my nemesis oh cool
so now go to different plane and once we
get there once we get there we can
switch language okay world map so this
is the world map this is why they say
it's not really an open world right yeah
exactly so like that one spot that we
were at before that's just one of these
sections so now there's like we heard
that if you fly straight up into the air
it'll take you to the world map oh
that's pretty cool what gives you gives
you the option so yeah you like press
circled and then it'll take you to the
world map if you just straight head
straight up but it's just faster to go
through the menu but it's a cool option
that they gave yeah which makes sense
because you're like you know getting out
of there but uh yeah after I save here
that it guess what's back to English and
then we can keep with the story yeah
anchors point we're gonna be oh yeah
that's where we're gonna fight reddit's
to get back to get our child back yeah
kidnapping as a crime yes was just
coming got a send the AMBER Alert out
for our child last seen in the hands of
a guy was extremely long hair
yes only those with pure heart
but yes you guys this game will
officially be out this Friday for those
you wondering luckily for us we're
getting uh switching back and forth
between languages just so everyone can
can enjoy it and check it out mixers
give you guys some you know samples yeah
English and there's Japanese fans here
so got a piece both there's no right
language it's just if there is Spanish
option I I would say we will put that on
too I would like to hear Spanish
Dragonball I never actually heard you
know I have always heard that like they
would watch new episodes and like the
new releases like on a big screen like
people watch and like everybody gets
super hype it's big it's huge they're
really yeah I've seen I've seen videos I
said okay I got a good and I bumped the
audio a little bit it's just kind of
hard cuz certain areas of gameplay is
louder than others yeah like some whites
get like really loud and then like just
keep adjusting through it what are the
combos like you talked about guards and
dodges but the combos are very important
this is location so the combos it's
fairly straightforward it's just kind of
a punch punch and then you can do like a
special afterwards at the end of the
combo but they're not 100 of foolproof
because not every single enemy is gonna
take the combo sometimes it could just
like get out of the combo start doing
their own attack and like interruptus
it's kind of weird it's not released a
skateboard system like in a fighting
game my console and you also don't have
all your ability
show yourself you could never beat me oh
yeah back to the English voice is really
deep no he's using a device that tells
him our strengths as well as our
location actually this where's my son
what's this a power level of seven ten
where the hell damn this thing must be
busted watch another reading and it's
heading straight for me there's one no
that's - yo levels 322 and 334 my son so
what brings you chumps here isn't it
obvious
I'm here to get my son back where is he
you're hiding him somewhere aren't you
screaming was giving me a headache but
forget about the runs don't tell me you
actually think you stand a chance
against me you fool you're not even fit
to call yourself a saying prepare to die
if anything the voice actress must have
a lot of fun
we're currently playing on these he
absorbs
[Applause]
I kinda wanted like an atmosphere to
feel sick like say denim
I'm always down with your combined power
you're still pathetic but considering
you weren't smart enough to heed my
warning don't deserve to live all things
like the lip-sync is with Joe that you
say as I mentioned earlier if you've got
a new attack hitting up your sleeve
now's the time to use it like such a
gentleman
does you needs a boat huh lucky for you
I actually came up with a new technique
while I was training it'd be easier just
to lie down and wait for the sweet
release of death I'm just gonna need
enough time to charge up the proper
energy for it
gonna need you to keep him busy while I
deal with this stuff so annoyed got it
I'll do what I can hope you're ready for
this three episodes you'll know when to
quit
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you have any supporters right now
the low boxes oh no we're gonna have to
wait for the next three strings to
finish
I'm trying to think of like how else
would be like the fighting style even
though like Dragon Ball fighters was
awesome like gameplay-wise doesn't
capture like this like this I actually
feel like an actual place yeah from
there
the gameplay feel
just like yeah like sometimes we'll just
super long
[Music]
does this have any good sighs mission oh
wait good work hold onto that tail and
don't let go no matter what
he pulled the family don't think I'm
going to show you mercy just because
you're my little brother
you're next
he'll know he's just going to dodge it
yeah my fun buffs come save me yeah oh
yeah
oh man I was getting invested there it's
a good story like seriously like
obviously there's a few things I'm like
[Music]
well you just were you idiot
trust me Goku won't be dead for very
long what didn't you know this planet is
home to the Dragon Balls they grant
wishes absolutely any wish imaginable
even bringing someone back from the dead
Walter why don't you tell him the
secrets of the Dragonball
[Music]
yeah one year before even stronger
warriors arrived
all right so we got one year yep but
don't you worry we're gonna bring you
back really soon interesting
I bet commie has something to do with
this we can put our minds at ease if
commies involved you guys need to get
the dragonballs commie doesn't possess
the power needed to bring someone back
to life also go goose kid will be coming
with me for the time being them with a
little training in the right teacher
that kid could be capable of serious
power we're going to need all the power
we can get before those two Saiyans show
tell him go get his son back and in
better shape than he left him all right
well that's right meanwhile on a planet
far far from Earth
Raddatz
bastard he always was an embarrassment
still I must admit I'm very interested
in these Dragon Balls so they're capable
of granting any wish all right let's go
we're gonna bring rats back from the
dead don't make me laugh
we have no more use for that dead weight
we could wish for eternal youth for
immortality can you imagine it nothing
could possibly stand in our way good to
me
[Music]
invigorated by the prospect of attaining
immortality with the dragonballs the two
sales made their way to earth a one-year
long trip to earth yeah that's far
that's a long time that's pretty far yes
he is very interested in there's like so
many things now that make well I don't
know if make more sense is the word but
then that I'm now realizing like they
wrap their tails around their waist like
a belt exactly yeah
I remember like seeing it but not
realizing that was very tail and I'm
like oh that is again like this is like
a great way to recap my like why if
things are the way they are and that is
why I brought him here as he is to be
trained further therefore if it is
agreeable to you King Yemma
I humbly ask that you allow him to meet
with King Kai hmm I see so you intend to
take this heaven bound soul and subject
him to the grueling 625,000 by a long
snake way so he can meet King Kai
[Music]
however I should warn you that no one
has ever ever made it successful myself
must be one heck of a journey through
here it sure did he definitely did he's
done done yeah you must be one heck of a
strong guy so you were sent along with
him huh I am the great king i occupy a
position
above the Earth's Guardian do you know
what that means
that means you're crazy strong right you
don't seem to understand what I'm saying
of course I'm strong but it's not just
my strength that serves me in this
position you need brains to do this kind
of managerial work wait a minute what
work to help you better understand my
work let's give you a little quiz okay
okay I'll take the quiz why did you say
that from the beginning anyway let's
begin I'll let you know if you can
answer all of my questions correctly
right next question who is more in fact
yeah yes Am I I feel like that's just
even if it's not true only earth
like your brother he wasn't an earthly
next question yes who created those
blasted balls which oh no wait okay so I
I was like doubling oh I was like
doubting myself when I saw his question
and this is actually the right answer
exactly the wrong it's correct I do
believe that was the fifth question of
course it was no I was just testing you
and you passed the test
[Music]
true fifth question there's that
trademark denial of his that's my stuff
boy he's got one hell of a sense of
hearing really thanks a bunch mr. yema
don't tell me you forgotten who you're
talking to
mr. King Yemma I haven't that's more
like it
if you're going to see King Kai then go
well this is where we part ways good
luck Goku Thanks
not really sure what to expect but I'm
pumped to meet this kink guy guy right
all right so we got more all right cool
so we're gonna go hopefully make it
there I'm assuming it's gonna be a rough
journey cuz he was like I'm the only one
and however many years thank you
well it's a they just they just skipped
the whole snake trail oh do you want to
do yes that's [ __ ] walking simulator
600 625 thousand miles of it exactly
like actual scale yeah game would be
like 9 million of his friends are
vigilant and able to find the
dragonballs that can bring him back
however we've got other things to deal
with though we were able to defeat
Raddatz it sounds like we've got two of
his buddies to worry about a year from
now time to be a man if that's really
the case your father and I probably
aren't going to be enough to take these
guys down
we need power your power you're going to
have to learn to fight and defend the
earth
you got it new dad this big-ass car so
chilled what is up homie welcome back
quit your whining catapulted your body
into rabbits done whipping you you'll be
tough enough for anything got it
you're gonna train me okay - do you have
to live out here on your own without
distraction I'm giving you six months if
you're able to survive for that home
I'll teach you how to fight that's the
biggest item ahead of me it's such a big
whoo you wake up there dad's dead yeah
you gotta save the earth and you're left
alone for six months and new dad is like
all right six months I'll see you oh my
god okay we taught you how to fish and I
can't run or do anything oh man this is
some struggle right here level one got
some herbs though
this is just raining right now I'm just
walking your food go get him go on
[Applause]
he's kind of cute there we go it's got
to learn to control it's never on
purpose
return to the battlefield Sony night out
of bounds oh okay got some framedrops
all right didn't go and get himself
killed already did he ten seconds there
you go
all right
oh snap we've unlocked some super tiny
little brat dies here and that's all
he'd ever amount to a little floor at no
mercy
go see how gohan doing well he's stuck
on top of this on top of this cliff
[Music]
amazing member these forums being Canada
energy from this thing is incredible
what the hell are those things
my kids probably got his hands full
right now I'll have to take care of them
myself
[Music]
come on you scumbags for buddy in the
chat oh man
but yes you can play this in English or
in Japanese we've showed off both for a
little bit so far this will officially
be available on Friday we're just lucky
enough to have a little bit of early
access here there is gonna be a day one
patch on Friday as well to shorten
loading times and other quality light
things so if you receive some of those
loading hands taking forever
that's not something you'll have to
worry about once you actually have the
game from what they say
does it look like a buys so far if
you're a fan Dragonball I would say yes
and even if you're new to Dragonball I
could also say yeah if you're new and
interested in learning about it because
yeah yeah it has everything I feel like
I'm already learning a lot and actually
becoming more interested in it as we're
going through the stories yeah like I
feel like if you want to be like super
into it then you can like watch the
anime at this point but like okay I want
to know all the like side things
happened because this is just like all
the important
and actually that we should go ahead and
end it here all righty
because that is gonna be right at our
ninety minutes but yeah we hope you guys
enjoyed what you saw in this first 90
minutes we did get through a pretty good
chunk of like what your story and
information so far I feel like so seems
like the pacing isn't isn't too slow
yeah it's stuff that keeps up and this
is like only halfway through the first
off and it's like so yeah you guys thank
you so much for tuning in we hope you
enjoyed it it's gonna be available this
Friday if you want to snag yourself a
copy there's obviously a bunch of
pre-order editions that come with a
bunch of different things so if you like
what you saw consider picking one up in
the meantime we're heading out of here
but every weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific
time right here on the GameSpot youtube
we're playin games so feel free to come
back tomorrow and you know Friday every
other day of the week daily stream
exactly so have a good one you guys
we'll see you later